que je peux vous dire un petit train
c'est la belle avoue votre garde des
plus devenir cédera guillotin
aujourd'hui je me fais passer pour un
serveur amnésique dans le piège qui va
suivre il ya une complice qui s'appelle
audrey et la piéger c'est sa maman
sandrine c'est parti merci
ça faisait longtemps pour ces phases de
six mois ce qui m'arrive à bien sans
vous l'avez venant mais non non je
connais pas d'accord alors je confonds
peu d'athlètes je vous amène les cartes
est-ce que vous avez un petit café avec
les desserts où commença avec quoi vous
êtes inondé corzé pas ok pardon au temps
pour moi ça vous met demander l'addition
bonjour moi si vous les cafés en fait je
pensais à faisait pas que ça marche je
vous appris votre votre commande
non moi je d'entre eux une autre quand
on voit que c'est noté j'ai perdu je
sais plus autre fleuron carnet c'était
deux cas la mare vous avez dit de
calamars de calamars ok ok avec moi donc
il y avait deux par terre avant de lui
demander le catch up enfin m
[Musique]
je vous encaissez maintenant vous voulez
repartir sur quelque chose et cause pour
les plats du coup je remercie
catoire content de cela
vous parlez en à castres je comprends
les deux secondes certaines votera lui
aussi pour les autres les antilles à
temps non mais vous plaisantez c'est
pour le gâteau dont je sens pris
maintenant il n'ya pas de gâteau
d'anniversaire où on veut les pleins pas
beaucoup mon nom n'y a pas qu'à tout
instant pensé un temps qu'on s'est
produit en pleine messe c'est pas s'il
va parvenir à passer a commenté theresa
traitement
en sens inverse de changer des choses
regardez
vous n'êtes pas français
[Musique]
est ce que sont les 3 bet
la tournée
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait partir le gâteau
d'anniversaire en cuisine donc ce sera
livré pour la fin du repas pas
d'inquiétude je me suis renseigné mis un
bon coup
6 à 7 81 55 euros cliquez sur la carte
les parties en cuisine agathois versa
vous voyez ça va être sympa ça commence
à bien faire si ça continue j'ai mal
partir sans pays bas vient votre ami ne
marche pas une surprise pour enfin la
commune iv fait la commande est ce qu'on
peut mettre les choses à plat
sinon je mets pas les choses à plat avec
vous ça suffit monsieur maman gâteau
d'anniversaire pour vous pour vous faire
un cadeau
ce n'est pas mon anniversaire d'accord
je suis né au mois de mars
je suis au mois de mars l'huile et au
mois de septembre est allé le mois de
juillet d'accord il n'y a pas
d'anniversaire
vous entendez la [ __ ] merde nom qui
commence à déraper le gars à 125 euros
je vais vous expliquer ce qui je parle
des choses que vous m'avez demandé et
qu'ensuite les cuisinières des matières
premières la seconde commande on n'a pas
ça car la vue qui versèrent c'est vous
qui l'avez inventé les armes égales et
l'entêtement des inverseurs s'il y a pas
d'anniversaire de m'expliquer vous le
prendre a remporté je vais vous faire
de toute manière moi je préférais vous
je vais voir la voilà pour les verrous
faire des excuses on est vraiment désolé
c'est en tout cas et par rapport au
trésor de george peppard crise et non
non la bourgeoisie combat est demandée
par rapport aux maraîchers c'est le mari
chi pour un cerisier
on a réellement vu rien bouleversé
d'arracher pour véhiculer en armement
dit là on a fini tu vois pour l'oscar
pas semblé moment des comptes chose
excusez moi non mais arrêtez c'est mon
petit à ses partenaires aux maraîchers
on n'a rien demandé c'est pas comme ça
[Musique]
mais madame j'en ai ras-le-bol donc
rendez-vous des atouts c'est pour demain
ça c'est madame qui va commander un je
m'appelle pas gâteront et bien vous
savez quoi la soirée que j'ai passé à
stop on accorde au gâteau vous allez y
brancher aloi 55e roi je pense souris
alors pour votre information je passais
le packaging
vous avez dit denise mais bien sûr non
mais foutez de ma gueule quoi un choix
vaut mieux en rire vous présenter ça
fait deux heures je suis là donc je veux
bien rire j'ai bien rigolé au début mais
là au bout de deux ans et demi
franchement rapide quatrième déco témoin
ne s'est pas catherine d'accord avec
vous arrêtez de parler terminé quatrième
je ne l'avais pas catherine j'habite
juste à côté juste à côté tu jamais vous
verrez magali si c'est clair qu'à très
bas là mais je ne m'appelle pas
catherine sans savoir vraiment parcourir
sinon il s'est même pas tenté c'est
inadmissible
faut arrêter les conneries mais je n'ai
fait rare scandale vous arrêter terminez
votre ami d'un non sens la belle actrice
bannissez pas d'anniversaire
tout ça parce que je peux vous dire un
petit mot c'est la balle à vous votre
caddie plein devenir
et écoutez moi s'il vous plaît tout ça
c'était une caméra cachée
[Applaudissements]
draghi l'auteur a vendu chez grégory
grégory grégory si vous nous rejoignez
c'est la grâce rapide et en direct la
grande rafle à trois ça continue les
chéris d'ailleurs il faudrait que ça
continue déchets rien ils n'ont pas mis
derrière voilà mais si la grande ratera
trois mois d'une levée relevé donc voila
merci au restaurant les initier à paris
aussi merci et permet de tourner à
catherine dumas galicienne david
douillet j'adore également catherine s
est pas crédible et denise 4 mais là je
[Applaudissements]
dois y fait beaucoup rire et vous êtes
vous êtes très calme ouais ben chauffer
un groupe il ya certes un poids réduit
et bon anniversaire à durer et on vous
offre la sur un cas de lannion 22 mars
et pour moi
[Musique]